[Music]
today's episode answer the internet is
brought to you by curve coming to the
united states soon it's going to change
the entire finance game stay tuned
afterwards for more details i'm howie
mandel i'm here on uh answering the
internet because i just want you to
watch me on netflix the show's [ __ ]
no it's good
it's called [ __ ] would you rather
have wet socks for a whole year
or a year-long cold wet socks because i
think you think that's bad
no
but first of all i don't want to be sick
because i'm a germaphobe and and when it
comes to feet one word moisturize
i'm wearing wet socks right now i don't
know why they're wet and that bothers me
but my socks are always wet if your tv
remote didn't work and you were sick and
couldn't get up all day
what channel would you put
on for the entire day i like the home
shopping network i like it there's that
lady you know the one with the she's got
like uh
she's a middle-aged woman maybe in her
50s or 60s and she's got the floral
dress
they know i like her i like her
i like her she was selling these um
pillow sets
is it enough to say oh i like i could
lie in bed all day with my wet socks on
watching that old lady in the flower
dress
selling pillow sets is it weird to
shampoo your pubes
it's all i have people
it's the conditioner that hurts
yes oh my god i'll tell you something
uh my testicles
yeah they're so conditioned
you know you can get uh like botox your
nuts now to smooth them out no you can't
you can get scrotux i wouldn't use
scrotux because then you couldn't tell
if i was excited that's where i show my
emotions
that's where i show my expressions look
how happy i am
two buttons you can only press one a
instantly get a million dollars or b
have a 50 50 chance you get 100
million dollars we're gonna up the one
million for you though let's say it's
yeah for me
no because i'll be honest with you i am
so [ __ ] rich
no this wouldn't even affect me it
wouldn't affect me that's why i can do
this internet [ __ ] for nothing it's not
you're not paying me so i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't press any button i don't
need your [ __ ] million
10 million or a shot at 100. i'll take
the 10 million i'll just press the
button take the 10 million and go home
because i have
where's your card
when would you switch over no because i
have an investment can i talk about it
right now sure
um it's in a bitcoin i have an nft
have you guys heard of these nfts i know
that i could take 10 million and within
hours i could turn it into the 100
million i'm good when it comes to
investing
issue your balls
is eating in bed gross
no eating in bed is okay it's licking
the pillow that's gross
what if you let's say let's say this one
with this i was just a hypothetical no
he's gonna ask me a question this is
hypothetical like every one of these has
not been
this one's hypothetical i've been
dealing with reality up until this
you you fall asleep in bed right you you
went to sleep and you eat tons of candy
you get like sour patch kids everywhere
maybe a couple melted reese's is it
gross to eat those like after you kind
of roll around on them no then they're
all soft and warm i like to when the
food when the food is in the bed and
then after a whole night of pressing you
know it's like a human panini yeah
no that's what it is you're joking but i
love it
no human panini you know what a panini
is where you put it in the thing and yet
what if you did that with your body you
wouldn't eat it i just flattened this
and it's sour patch kids is your choice
for bed would you rather have teeth
where your hair is
where the [ __ ] is that
eyebrows or hair where your teeth are
would you have to comb your teeth after
every meal
yeah yeah yeah like you would that's a
good question
you'd have to comb yeah like brush your
hair after every meal mouth hair yeah
eating would be a yeah but you know what
i bet no wouldn't because you ever get
food in your hair right so it's a good
thing it's easy to get out and if your
teeth were hair
it's like built-in floss but then so
then the other choice would i rather
have teeth
i'd rather cornrows but like teeth oh
just here like here yeah
what side would you part your teeth
i would go to the middle part oh like
letterman
i like that i want a big space i want a
gap i want a gap here i'm gonna do that
you know what if you had hair if you had
teeth where your hair there'd be no
reason to do that
[Music]
oh and it gets something out of your
tooth there's something in my tooth
[Laughter]
would you rather every time you meet
someone you have to tell them you got
your degree online from the university
of phoenix and then say i am a phoenix
or change your name to oliver and not be
able to use anything
let me say hi i'm oliver i'm just trying
it out i'm a phoenix
i'm oliver a phoenix
anything you say
at the wrong volume just sounds creepy
yeah like even your own name right if
you set it
low and almost whispered it just sounds
creepy like if you just walked up to a
stranger and went i'm howie
it's not good it's not good right so i'm
oliver
but i did i i won
i won oh
i'm a phoenix
you know what's weird this is my actual
voice
i talk like this so people won't make
fun of me
are you tired of managing all these
different cards in your wallet get rid
of them just get the curve card you can
put your debit card your credit cards
and everything all on this one easy to
use card plus earn extra rewards on top
of your regular rewards coming to the
united states soon go to curve.com
barstool to get on the waiting list
today oh look there's a pig [ __ ] a
lion
would you rather be a pig and be able to
orgasm
oh the question yes i was gonna answer
it okay would you rather be a pig and be
able to orgasm for 30 minutes
or be a lion and be able to have sex 60
times a day
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't want to keep [ __ ] and then
nothing happens
i wanna i'm a pig
i'm all over the pins
and i'm orgasing for 30 minutes
need that you [ __ ]
oh my god
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get em make sure you subscribe
to the channel right now